Speaker 1: The arrests continue for people
involved in the January 6th Trump riots.
And the Justice Department has now charged
a soldier in the Wisconsin National Guard
for his involvement in the insurrection.
On January 6th, Abraham Markovsky and an associate
report, CNN allegedly traveled to Washington,
D.C., together to attend Trump's protest against
the certification of the 2012 election after
the rally.
Investigators say Markovsky and his associate
walked to the Capitol, spent 40 minutes inside
the building.
Markovsky has been charged with four federal
crimes, including violent entry or disorderly
conduct.
As of this morning, he has not yet entered
a plea.
Markovsky is one of the nearly three dozen
current or former service members charged
in connection with the January 6th attack,
says CNN.
Based on a review of Pentagon records and
court documents.
The majority are veterans, including many
who served in Iraq and Afghanistan.
But Markovsky is part of a smaller group in
that he is, or at least was, a current member
of the military.
This is not hugely shocking.
In the immediate aftermath of the January
6th Trump riots, we knew that there was not
only a military presence but a law enforcement
presence.
I'm not saying to defend the capital there
was that, but I'm saying in terms of the perpetrators
and now we are learning more about the specifics
of this overrepresentation in the group of
writers in the defendants charged with their
involvement on January 6th.
Military and law enforcement are overrepresented,
although not by as much as it may be looked
like earlier on.
Now, this action by Markovsky seems to be
in violation, not just a federal law, but
also of the National Guard oath.
It looks like it's in violation of an article
banning mutiny and sedition.
The National Guard oath says, I solemnly swear
that I will support and defend the constitution
of the US and of the state of whatever, because
National Guards or state National Guards against
all enemies, foreign and domestic, I will
bear true faith and allegiance to them, and
I will obey the orders of the president of
the United States and the governor of whatever
state and the orders of the officers appointed
to me according to law and regulations, clearly
a violation by participating in the riot of
the National Guard oath.
But then also looking at Article ninety four
on Mutiny and sedition, any person subject
to this chapter who with intent to usurp or
override lawful military authority, refuses
in concert with any other person to obey orders
or otherwise do his duty or creates any violence
or disturbance is guilty of mutiny.
That is exactly what the January 6th riots
were about.
So although the charges so far are just federal,
I'm seeing significant reason that there should
be charges here under the US Code of Military
Justice as well, at least for this individual,
if not for others as well.
Now, in terms of, you know, consequences and
penalties, it's just too early.
There are certainly people who are going to
do some jail time for their participation
in the January 6th riots.
Many are going to plead out and we just have
to wait and see.
But we're continuing to see active service
members charged in they're involved for their
involvement in the January 6th riots.
Let me know what you expect as far as sentencing
on some of these.
Will being a member of the military be an
aggravating factor in sentencing or will it
be a mitigating factor in sentencing?
If indeed we get to that point?
Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a perfect, perfect show for you today.
Glad you're
with us.